quel est maintenant temps pierre laurens
d'emmanuel james à lyon explique ben
pour nous trois cents pages pour lui
faire comprendre que tu recules tatave
sept trophées citations ainsi non mais
c'est un petit pays où boire et un
médecin dès ce soir en allant chercher
ça au début quand je t'ai vu fred j'ai
pensé que ça sent dirais je t'aime
tellement
il faut que je t'aime comme je suis ce
qu'on veut je veux être une femme d'être
heureux comme ça s'est arrangé les
choses
tu crois que j'ai de martyriser j'ai
pensé que je suis de mauvaise mère jean
vous
que les on ne revit avec les tempèrent
ton père vaudra semaine par un sale j'ai
besoin de toi fred sont tous gérés 20
pas
pour faire son sens
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas pu rentrer ce matin
c'est
c'est une révolte
non sire c'est une révolution notre
génération capables d'apprendre seul en
est rendu là j'ai des 10 depuis combien
de temps
depuis aujourd'hui montfrin fun sur plus
sympa par rencontre avec toi c'est quoi
le commandât que tintin le plus souvent
c'est vrai que c'est spécial
on a préféré vous tenir à l'écart les
penseurs du board reddition qu'est ce
que c'est c'est un article tout pas
s'arranger
on aurait pu ensemble
berthe et un autre tweet crise oui un
long moment c'est moi c'est laurence pas
peut-être aller prendre une marche parce
que ça va pas mal monté un portable
c'est important j'ai jamais eu
l'impression que c'était ma mère
moi j'ai jamais eu l'impression était
mon fils
quatre ans j'ai l'impression que ma vie
un personne qui parraine cette histoire
sur toile non parce que là c'est toi qui
ont essayé mais ce peut pas tout avoir
j'ai choisi des sons de la france dans
la peau d'une femme toutes les femmes la
descente après l'avoir monté
quand tu déjà acheté une paire pourtant
tu as toi tu déjà eu peur comme ça de
chez vous qui se fasse tabasser d'henry
qui ne reviennent pas vraiment sens
[Musique]
cet organe